[Musique]
vous avez peut-être déjà vu cette photo
la jeune afghane aux yeux verts une
photo emblématique signé steve mccurry
qui a fait le tour du monde qui s'est
retrouvé à la une du magazine national
geographic
mais c'est une photo qui a aussi son lot
de controverses tellement il leur fallut
altérer la photo originale pour en
arriver au résultat final
alors le photojournalisme reflète-t-il
toujours la réalité
est-ce qu'il ya pas lieu parfois de
parler de désinformation je vais aller
en parler avec ivanoh demers
photojournaliste profession ça va
bientôt faire une question se retrouver
bloqués
[Musique]
la trame est dépassé c'est là que la
magie opère
alors de bannu dans votre commence le
travail de postproduction aussi là où on
commence à jouer un petit peu avec la
réalité
ouais on va faire les étapes une par une
ok le recadrage la densité l'exposition
le contraste satisfaire les tons classe
je baise et ont foncé saveur et la
balance des blancs jamais un petit peu
plus de bleu altération de base densité
contraste les hautes lumières les basses
lumières c'est pas mal ça longval l
esprit trop loin d'augmenter de 40%
contre as tu as vu comment s'est rendu
dramatique alors lorsqu'on va faire on
va brûler la côte est super king james a
joué blessé
on va voir si on peut d'un côté la
conférence un peu plus dramatiques de
l'autre côté il en définitive mais trop
loin
après ça pendant les graphistes le
pupitre voit la photo il va choisir un
titre de la journaliste veut mettre un
texte qui va l'accompagner ça
n'influence ne tiens moi chaque fois
chaque étape il ya eu un reportage dans
le sud des états unis puisque des images
des bases assez forte déjà puis le
photographe a décidé mais vraiment
d'aller trop loin les couleurs sont
tellement en bon français créquy qu'elle
devienne dénaturer il ya cette autre le
convoi avec cet homme torse et lil wayne
le photographe a voulu isoler la croix
gammée jacques la zone à l'arrière au
tour a été mais vraiment brûlé de façon
complètement ridicule il ya plus de
détails sur les côtés j'avais été à côté
du photographe sait pas ce que j'ai vu
on fait pas notre travail et on est pas
personne en faisant ça parce que c'est
de la désinformation tout simplement
tout simplement c'est de la
désinformation
oui à 25 qui se passait devant toi mais
a au moins autant les couleurs le
contraste en brûlant tout ce qui se
passe autour
donc là voulant dire qu'ils allaient
sujet de façon dramatique ça représente
pas la réalité
est-ce que c'est inquiète sont dans une
certaine mesure que de plus en plus les
outils technologiques qui sa mère parce
que la secte rapidement pavés ça devient
un peu comme la norme
les gens sont habitués à tout modifie
sur instagram tout le temps c'est normal
pour eux à la russe disant photo gens
disent pourquoi qu'on pourrait pas le
faire
justement on ne peut pas le faire il
faut pas la faire restons vigilants
oui il faut être vigilant qu'il faut
garder l'oeil ouvert un petit c'est trop
beau des x men c'est pas vrai
[Musique]